we are very excited about our next guest
it's actress daisy edgar jones she's
best known for her role as marianne in
the wildly popular tv show normal people
did you see that
now she's starring in the highly
anticipate
highly anticipated new movie call where
the craw dad sing it is based on the
best-selling novel the same name this
book is huge
daisy plays the main character kaia who
raised herself in the marshlands of
north carolina kyah is charged with
murder after a man she had a romantic
relationship is found dead this is all
in the trailer so we're not giving
anything away in this clip kaia's lawyer
tries to convince her to testify so the
jury sees what a kind and good person
she is here's a look
i know you have a world of reasons to
hate these people no i never hated them
they hated me
i mean they laughed at me
they left me
they harassed me they attacked me
you want me to beg for my life
i don't have it in me
i won't
i will not
offer myself up that he can make their
decision
but they're not deciding
anything about me
whoa daisy edgar joins
daisy edgar jones let's try that again
gail joins us in the studio good morning
to you movie star and i say that because
last night was the movie premiere it was
your first what was that like for you
daisy it was crazy it was crazy it was a
year ago to the day kind of that we
finished filming so to actually be there
finding all together as well because
most of the crew i only saw half their
face because they were wearing masks
yeah it was really lovely just to be
there yeah you know what i think is so
interesting is that you have you're
british so you had to learn a southern
accent
how difficult was that for you did you
have certain phrases that you you work
with the dialect coach
i didn't know you were british really oh
really no i didn't yeah i i worked
because it would have been a bit strange
if kaya had a north london accent it was
really important to try and get that
right are there certain phrases for you
yeah i love to
get out of my lagoon you low down dirty
creep was one that i really i really
liked because i had to scream that line
and and how do you say it with your
american accent
it's been a while it's been a while like
get out of my lagoon i mean yeah there
you go there you go yeah sometimes it
would go a bit australian but um but
yeah that one was helpful and north
carolina's thing so so kaya your
character in the movie based on the book
is a kind of
genius naturalist in the marsh did you
have to learn a lot about the marsh
yourself in order to embody her yeah i
tried to you know in in the book that
it's based on um
there's a lot of books that are
referenced within that so i tried to
read all of the books that kaia was
reading and and actually just filming on
location was incredible you know i'd
never been in an environment like it and
for kya she has such a love and respect
to that environment so to actually be
able to be on location not be you know
on the sound stage having to imagine it
all was so so helpful how quickly did
you walk back to your trailer after a
scene because it's swampy right right
i was wondering about conditions too
there i mean this is tony yeah accurate
behind it yeah it's funny because when
you watch the film it looks so beautiful
but you can't also feel the like intense
humidity and mosquito bites that were
also a part of the experience so um yeah
it was it wasn't always very comfortable
but it looked really good awesome so one
of the things that's really fascinating
is taylor swift surprised everyone when
she wrote a song for the film and we
were playing a little bit earlier it's
called carolina and she posted on
instagram as soon as she heard that you
were starring in this film and that it
was being produced by reese witherspoon
she knew that she had to write something
uh she wanted to be a part of it um what
was your reaction to that that taylor
swift is saying yeah daisy edgar jones
you're in this i gotta compose a song
yeah i mean it's just it's bonkers
really is the only way i could i could
describe it i am i i didn't know taylor
had had written a song for i knew
somebody had but they wouldn't tell me
who so i found out when the trailer uh
came out as well so you found out when
we found out yeah i think i said like i
found out when they're trying to yeah
that's for mark i think i saw the
trailer like the day before so i like
fell off my chair and was like what
but her song is so beautiful this is a
movie where it's hard to overstate how
big the book that it's based on really
is millions and millions and millions of
copies so for people who know the book
uh and i don't know the book i know the
movie what do you how faithful is it
what do you say to readers who want to
see the film i mean i think it's
incredibly faithful to the book you know
i think you're really left with the same
feeling when the film ends that you're
left with when you put the book down you
know and i think you know it's quite
there's a large amount in this story to
cover you know there's a murder mystery
there's a love story there's a survival
story and i think it's a love story to
nature too it is a love letter to nature
and i think um i think the filmmakers
have done just such an excellent job of
capturing all of those elements and the
heart of kaya so well i got the book
when it first came out because there was
such buzz and i thought i'm going to
read i'm going to read it now i've seen
the movie now i definitely want to read
the book but this was this is what re
said about you daisy edgar jones is a
once in a lifetime talent she can morph
herself into many different characters
what do you think when you see that
daisy because most people knew you were
british they knew normal people that was
huge and now you're going to a next
level what does it feel like for you at
this time you know it's so surreal like
um you know i i used to take the tube
all the time to my auditions and things
like that now there's a poster in my
local tube station and my friends keep
sending it to me and with your face with
my face
it's really special and i just feel very
lucky you know i love acting and um i
love i love the people i get to work
with and meet and i just feel very lucky
to to be doing it really that's
beautiful i can't wait for people to see
the movie you were so good in it and you
nailed every every scene that you were
in and this is one where it's worth
going to the theater yes i agree the big
immersive story it's so true because i
had to watch it on my ipad it's not the
same and i cried at the end i have to
say i was crying at the end yes i have
it too much away all right
they were happy i know they were happy
too because i like too
daisy edgar jones thank you thank you
thank you and bravo cheering you on you
can see where the craw dad's what's a
crawdad guys it's a little shrimp
crayfish a little crayfish where the
crawdads sing i thought it was a big bug
and theater's starting on friday